gifted is directed by Marc Webb and
stars Chris Evans as a guardian of a
young girl who is incredibly smart in
fact she's basically a genius on her
first day in school she shocked the
entire class and her teachers and it
eventually becomes very clear that this
is a young child prodigy when it comes
to math so now we have a question could
the next Einstein have a normal life
while also being the next Einstein and
all the problems that come with trying
to raise a young child who doesn't
really necessarily want to be the next
Einstein but really likes going to the
beach and having a cat and playing and
being a little girl I was pretty happy
to see Marc Webb back directing a movie
like this because I'm a big fan of 500
days of summer and not so much the
amazing spider-man 1 and 2 I feel like
he's really at home in this film this is
a film that takes its time to have
characters just sit around or walk
around and talk I really really liked
that it was so refreshing to see a film
where characters are you know walking
around some green screen environment
there's no explosions there's no action
set-pieces
this is just a film about characters
it's a small cast but it's a big story
it's a story we've seen before Jodie
Foster made a movie in the 90s called
little man Tate which was also about a
child prodigy this isn't anything that
we haven't really seen before but what
makes this movie special is the
performances and its sense about its
story in pretty much every movie about a
young child prodigy there's usually some
background war with adults where they're
trying to argue about what's best for
the child and the child never really
gets a say in this film it's less about
that and more about can a child have
both can a kid be the next Albert
Einstein while also going to the park
and being a Girl Scout and just having a
fun life as a kid and this is where
Chris Evans character becomes really
compelling to me because as I said he's
her uncle and his sister has since
passed away so he's trying to honor some
of her wishes while also realizing that
he has one of the smartest children
alive living with him so he's trying to
take into consideration a lot of
different people's viewpoints on one
little girl while also just trying to
make her smile and give her breakfast
morning and all the basic things that a
child would need and I found this movie
very endearing very heartfelt extremely
well acted Chris Evans is really really
good in this movie also Jenny slate is
terrific but the real star of this movie
is the little girl McKenna Grace who is
a star in the making this will be
difficult for her to find roles that
aren't like that exact type of role
because you know how Hollywood works
when you see a child actor in a film you
automatically start thinking of them
that way Macaulay Culkin dealt with that
he had a hard time getting roles that
weren't like some cute little
mischievous child but I think she's good
enough in this film to really break the
mold and do other things in the future
because her performance really is that
good and she did tug on my heartstrings
fairly successfully and that was
something I was concerned about whenever
I go to movies like this I don't want
them to be too sappy or too melodramatic
to Hallmark Channel you guys know what I
mean and this film I think did it just
right except for a few moments towards
the end there's as I said some courtroom
proceedings and this film falls into
that category of films where some legal
stuff has to happen some stuff that will
probably really bore the audience so
let's just kind of gloss over that and
skip to what they really want to see
whenever movies do that I'm kind of like
okay well that was kind of a cheap way
of continuing the story but that's
really my only major complaint with this
movie I found this to be an extremely
enjoyable movie that had a lot of
fantastic acting and was a unique
perspective on a similar story that we
have seen with another really great
supporting turn by Octavia Spencer who
again is in another really good movie
about a girl who's good at math
interesting I just made that connection
in my head the most charming thing about
the movie easily is the chemistry
between McKenna grace and Chris Evans
this unlikely father-daughter pair even
though they're not actually
father/daughter I found totally
believable and extremely lovable this is
the type of movie that I think more
people should see a movie like this
could actually inspire people to want to
make films or get into mathematics we
have a lot of really big fun SuperDuper
amazing movies that are going to be
coming out this summer but I hope more
people see films like this and it's
currently playing in a semi limited
release and I hope you guys do check it
out because I think it's worth watching
I'm going to give gifted Abby
plus guys thank you so much as always
for watching stay tuned this weekend I'm
going to have a review for as I said
another big gigantic movie called fate
of the Furious and this Sunday is a huge
really long video for my friend Matt and
I talked about alien 3 we have differing
viewpoints on this film and we wanted to
talk about the pre-production all the
different script drafts of what could
have happened and what eventually did
happen and talk about both cuts the
assembly cut me into actual to look
forward to that guys you're the best
thank you very much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuff mine eyes
[Music]